Hi, my name is Emily. I am a master's student studying clinical psychology at Southampton. I bought the book The Clinical Psychologist Collective to help myself prepare for my first round of doctorate applications and I'm so glad I did. Seeing how others have reflected on their journeys has been so insightful and it's given me a lot to reflect about with my own journey and skills. It's also helped to put things into perspective and reminded me that if I don't get onto the doctorate this year, that's okay. I think the most unexpected pleasure of this book, however, was just how inspirational
你好，我叫艾米丽。我是南安普顿大学临床心理学专业的硕士生。我买了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，来帮助自己准备第一轮博士申请，我很高兴我这么做了。看到其他人如何反思他们的旅程，我深受启发，这也让我对自己的人生旅程和技能有了很多思考。它还帮助我以正确的视角看待事物，并提醒我，如果今年没能考上博士，那也没关系。然而，我认为这本书最意想不到的乐趣在于，每个人的旅程是多么鼓舞人心。
each and every person's journey was. And using these stories as my morning motivation each day has been such a pleasure. I'm almost reluctant to come to the end. What happens when trauma doesn't just happen once, but over years? When your body and brain are shaped by constant fear, neglect or harm, the result isn't just PTSD, it's complex PTSD. Today we are talking about what complex trauma really is, how it shows up in adulthood, and most importantly how healing is possible. I'll be sharing a fictional but realistic case study of Sarah, whose childhood experiences
每天早上用这些故事来激励自己真是一种享受。我几乎舍不得读完它。当创伤不仅仅发生一次，而是持续多年时会怎样？当你的身体和大脑被持续的恐惧、忽视或伤害所塑造时，结果不仅仅是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），而是复杂性创伤后应激障碍（C-PTSD）。今天我们要讨论什么是真正的复杂性创伤，它在成年期是如何表现的，以及最重要的是，治愈是如何可能的。我将分享一个虚构但真实的案例研究——莎拉，她童年的经历
led to a lifelong struggle with anxiety, self-doubt and relationships until she found the right help. Stay tuned because understanding complex trauma could well change the way you think about your own or someone else's mental health forever. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you to everybody who watched my previous episode on complex PTSD and OCD where I met with Alexandra who spoke through her own experiences of this and it's got lovely feedback, lots of views, lots of comments. If you haven't watched it or listened to it already, please do. However, I did also get a recent comment from somebody
导致她一生都在与焦虑、自我怀疑和人际关系问题作斗争，直到她找到了合适的帮助。请继续收听，因为了解复杂性创伤可能会永远改变你对自己或他人心理健康的看法。你好，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。感谢每一位观看我上一期关于复杂性PTSD和强迫症（OCD）节目的观众，在那期节目中，我采访了亚历山德拉，她讲述了自己在这方面的经历，节目获得了很好的反馈，有很多观看量和评论。如果你还没有观看或收听，请务必去看看。不过，我最近也收到了一条评论，来自某人
that they had thought when they saw the title, this would be an informational video rather than one person's case study. They would welcome more of an explainer. So this is what today's episode is going to be. If you've got any feedback about this episode or future episodes you'd like to see, please do drop them in the comments
说他们看到标题时，以为这是一个信息类视频，而不是一个人的案例研究。他们更希望看到解释性的内容。所以这就是今天这一集要讲的内容。如果你对这一集或未来你想看到的剧集有任何反馈，请务必在评论区留言
or get in contact with me via my social media where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent Everywhere. If you've ever heard the phrase complex trauma, complex PTSD or even C-PTSD but maybe wondered what it is, this is going to be a great episode for you. Because today we are going to cover what constitutes or what makes up complex trauma, how it shapes the brain and the body, a case study of what complex trauma might look like in real life and what healing can look like. So whether you're working or have an interest in psychology yourself, whether you have lived experience of complex trauma or you love someone who does, this is going to be a brilliant episode which gives you plenty of insight, validation,
或者通过我的社交媒体与我联系，我在所有平台上都是“玛丽安·特伦特博士”。如果你曾经听说过“复杂性创伤”、“复杂性PTSD”甚至“C-PTSD”这些词，但可能想知道它们是什么，那么这一集非常适合你。因为今天我们将涵盖什么是复杂性创伤，它如何塑造大脑和身体，一个现实生活中复杂性创伤可能是什么样子的案例研究，以及治愈可能是什么样子的。所以，无论你是在从事心理学工作还是对此感兴趣，无论你是否有复杂性创伤的亲身经历，或者你爱的人有这种经历，这都将是一集精彩的节目，它会为你提供大量的见解、验证、
hope and action plans too. So number one, what is complex trauma? When people imagine trauma and what that might look like, people often perhaps think about a single event. That might be a car crash or witnessing an accident or hurting yourself physically. It usually involves feeling pretty terrified. But complex trauma happens when someone experiences
希望和行动计划。那么第一点，什么是复杂性创伤？当人们想象创伤及其表现形式时，通常会想到单一事件。那可能是一场车祸、目睹事故或身体受伤。它通常涉及感到非常恐惧。但复杂性创伤发生在某人经历
chronic repeated trauma over months or years, often in their childhood. In fact, we often screen for the first 18 years of someone's life. Common causes of complex trauma include growing up with neglect or emotional abuse, experiencing physical or sexual abuse, having a caregiver with untreated mental illness
持续的、反复的创伤，长达数月或数年，通常是在童年时期。事实上，我们经常会对一个人生命的前18年进行筛查。复杂性创伤的常见原因包括在忽视或情感虐待中长大、经历身体或性虐待、拥有患有未治疗精神疾病的照顾者
or addiction, being placed in foster care or experiencing other attachment disruptions. Because this type of trauma occurs in early life, it shapes the developing brain. This can lead to long-term effects on emotions, identity and relationships. This type of trauma is often called type two trauma, with type one trauma being the single event trauma,
或成瘾者、被寄养或经历其他依恋中断。由于这种类型的创伤发生在生命早期，它会塑造正在发育的大脑。这可能导致对情绪、身份和人际关系的长期影响。这种类型的创伤通常被称为“二型创伤”，而“一型创伤”是单一事件创伤，
such as the accidents or injuries. Okay, so now we've got a bit of an overview about what complex trauma is. Let's have a look at how it might look in a fictional case study example. Obviously the content of today's conversation might feel triggering if this feels like it resonates with you.
例如事故或伤害。好了，现在我们对什么是复杂性创伤有了一个大致的了解。让我们来看看它在一个虚构的案例研究中可能是什么样子的。显然，如果今天的谈话内容让你产生共鸣，可能会触发你的情绪。
Please do look after yourself and if you feel like now might not be the right time to watch or to listen to this episode or if you're around young ears, please do choose to come back at a later stage. So let me introduce you to Sarah. She is a fictional case study but her experiences are based on real people with complex PTSD. So let's take a little look at Sarah's childhood. Sarah grew up in a household where
请务必照顾好自己，如果你觉得现在不是观看或收听这一集的合适时机，或者如果你身边有年幼的孩子，请选择稍后再回来。那么，让我向你介绍莎拉。她是一个虚构的案例研究，但她的经历是基于患有复杂性PTSD的真实人群。让我们来看看莎拉的童年。莎拉在一个家庭中长大，
her parents were constantly arguing and her dad had violent outbursts. Sometimes he would hit her mum and Sarah would hide in the bathroom feeling completely terrified. She never knew what mood dad would be in when he got home from work. Sometimes he'd be fine. Sometimes he'd be fun. Sometimes he would explode over what seemed to be the smallest thing. In order to stay safe, Sarah seemed to learn that she had to be small, quiet and pleasing to those around her. She became overly independent from a young age. She never expressed her emotions because it felt like it was safer not to. She over achieved at school, trying to stay good to avoid conflict. So what was Sarah's adulthood like? Well, if we fast forward into Sarah's 30s, she
她的父母经常争吵，父亲有暴力倾向。有时他会打她的母亲，莎拉会躲在浴室里感到非常恐惧。她从不知道父亲下班回家时会是什么心情。有时他很好。有时他很有趣。有时他会因为看似最小的事情而爆发。为了保持安全，莎拉似乎学会了她必须变得渺小、安静，并取悦周围的人。她从小就变得过度独立。她从不表达自己的情绪，因为觉得不表达更安全。她在学校里追求卓越，努力表现良好以避免冲突。那么莎拉的成年生活是怎样的呢？好吧，如果我们快进到莎拉30多岁时，她
is a high functioning professional, but behind the scenes she struggles with anxiety, especially when she feels like she's upset somebody. She can't relax, she's always on edge waiting for things to go wrong. She has low self-worth, low self-esteem, feeling like she's never good enough. And I'm sorry to say that Sarah seems to attract controlling partners. This is a case where repeating patterns are playing out from childhood. A quick note on other complex trauma experiences. While Sarah's story hasn't included sexual abuse, for many this is what has happened in their childhood or young adulthood. Sexual abuse survivors often experience deep-rooted shame and self-blame, dissociation, a feeling of disconnection from their body, trust and intimacy issues. So of course, everybody's journey is so unique
是一位高能力的专业人士，但在幕后，她一直在与焦虑作斗争，尤其是当她觉得惹恼了某人时。她无法放松，总是处于紧张状态，等待着事情出错。她自我价值感低，自尊心低，觉得自己永远不够好。我很遗憾地说，莎拉似乎总是吸引控制欲强的伴侣。这是一个童年时期重复模式上演的案例。关于其他复杂性创伤经历的简要说明。虽然莎拉的故事不包括性虐待，但对许多人来说，这就是他们在童年或成年早期发生的事情。性虐待幸存者经常经历根深蒂固的羞耻感和自责、解离、与身体的疏离感、信任和亲密关系问题。所以当然，每个人的旅程都是如此独特，
and that's why trauma informed therapy is so useful because it should be bespoke and tailor-made to that person and their own unique experiences. If you would find it helpful to watch or listen to a full episode on this, please do let me know in the comments. So our third section, how does complex trauma show up in adulthood?
这就是为什么创伤知情疗法如此有用的原因，因为它应该是定制的，并针对那个人及其独特的经历量身定做。如果你觉得观看或收听关于这个主题的完整剧集会有帮助，请务必在评论中告诉我。所以我们的第三部分，复杂性创伤在成年期是如何表现的？
For many people, complex PTSD doesn't always look exactly like PTSD. In PTSD, you might have what's kind of feels like a classic flashback, where something that happened from the past is playing out in the present. That's not always the case with complex PTSD. Instead, it can show up as chronic anxiety
对许多人来说，复杂性PTSD并不总是看起来和PTSD完全一样。在PTSD中，你可能会有类似于经典的闪回，即过去发生的事情在现在重演。复杂性PTSD并不总是这样。相反，它可能表现为慢性焦虑
and hypervigilance, a sense of being on edge and tightly sprung and ready to react. It might look like emotional numbness or dissociation. It might feature struggles with boundaries and people pleasing. There might be a sense of feeling disconnected from your own needs, thinking that they don't matter or just not noticing them at all. And super commonly, there can be unexplained physical symptoms like migraines, IBS, fatigue, spinal, disc, neck, back problems, fibromyalgia. The list can be really long. For Sarah, this showed up as a sense that she always had to prove herself, never being
和过度警觉，一种处于紧张状态、紧绷并随时准备反应的感觉。它可能表现为情绪麻木或解离。它可能表现为在界限和取悦他人方面的挣扎。可能会有一种与自己的需求脱节的感觉，认为它们不重要，或者根本没有注意到它们。而且非常常见的是，可能会有无法解释的身体症状，如偏头痛、肠易激综合征（IBS）、疲劳、脊柱、椎间盘、颈部、背部问题、纤维肌痛。清单可能非常长。对莎拉来说，这表现为一种她必须时刻证明自己的感觉，永远无法
able to relax because she felt like she was stuck in survival mode. If any of this sounds familiar, it's not just who you are or your personality, it's a trauma response. Okay, so section four, our healing and therapy approaches for people with complex trauma. So healing from complex trauma is absolutely possible, but it requires the right therapeutic approach. I work one-to-one with people with complex trauma and I tend to weave Compassion Focused Therapy or CFT through everything that I do. CFT is an approach designed to help people struggling with shame, self-criticism and trauma by strengthening their ability to be compassionate both towards themselves and
放松，因为她觉得她被困在生存模式中。如果这些听起来很熟悉，那不仅仅是你的人格，这是一种创伤反应。好了，第四部分，针对复杂性创伤患者的治愈和治疗方法。所以，从复杂性创伤中治愈是绝对可能的，但它需要正确的治疗方法。我与复杂性创伤患者进行一对一的工作，我倾向于将“同情聚焦疗法”（CFT）贯穿于我所做的一切中。CFT是一种旨在通过加强人们对自己和
others. It's based on the understanding that our brains evolved to have a threat system which is focused on danger and survival, a drive system pushing us to achieve our goals, and a soothing system which allows us to feel safe and cared for. For many trauma survivors, the threat system is overactive and they struggle to access the feelings of safety or self-kindness. In the context of PTSD and complex trauma, CFT is especially helpful for those who experience deep shame or self-criticism. It provides a pathway to self-acceptance and emotional resilience. And now feels like a great time to tell you about the Our Tricky Brain Psycho-Education Kit, which uses compassion-focused therapy to help
他人的同情心，来帮助那些与羞耻感、自我批评和创伤作斗争的人的方法。它基于这样一种理解：我们的大脑进化出了一个专注于危险和生存的威胁系统，一个推动我们实现目标的驱动系统，以及一个让我们感到安全和被关怀的舒缓系统。对于许多创伤幸存者来说，威胁系统过度活跃，他们难以获得安全感或自我关怀。在PTSD和复杂性创伤的背景下，CFT对于那些经历深层羞耻感或自我批评的人特别有帮助。它提供了一条通往自我接纳和情绪韧性的途径。现在感觉是告诉你们“我们的棘手大脑心理教育工具包”的好时机，它使用同情聚焦疗法来帮助
professionals in working through people's trauma, depression and grief. If you would like £10 off the kit please use the code YouTube10 and head to my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk. So as I said I weave CFT through everything that I do. But there are also other approaches that I use and that are recommended for complex trauma too. So let's take a little look at those. So EMDR, you might have heard of that one. It's Eye Movement Desensitisation and Reprocessing.
专业人员处理人们的创伤、抑郁和悲伤。如果你想获得10英镑的工具包折扣，请使用代码YouTube10并前往我的网站www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk。正如我所说，我将CFT贯穿于我所做的一切中。但我也使用其他方法，这些方法也被推荐用于复杂性创伤。所以让我们来看看这些。所以EMDR，你可能听说过这个。它是“眼动脱敏再加工”。
I would say probably one of the biggest people to talk publicly about having received EMDR is Prince Harry. Of course he had a very unusual childhood and he spoke about feelings of disconnection from those that were raising him, especially after his mum Princess Diana died in a really tragic way. So what EMDR does is it helps the stuff from the past to kind of lay flatter. It's really good for processing, distressing memories and reducing trauma triggers.
我想说，公开谈论接受过EMDR的人中，最著名的人之一可能是哈里王子。当然，他有一个非常不寻常的童年，他谈到了与抚养他的人之间的疏离感，特别是在他的母亲戴安娜王妃以非常悲惨的方式去世之后。所以EMDR所做的是，它帮助过去的事情变得平淡一些。它对于处理痛苦的记忆和减少创伤触发因素非常有效。
This means that it helps to kind of assimilate things into people's lives so they feel less jagged and so that they feel like they took place many years ago rather than being really recent. Often when I'm working with someone using EMDR, they might say something to me like, wow, I've just realised this happened like, you know, 17 years ago, but I realised that until now ago, but I've realised that until now, it felt like it was still happening. And that is what EMDR helps you to do. I always think of it a little bit like dry cleaning for the brain or, you know, when you use a dishwasher and you're like, wow, that is squeaky clean. For me, it's like that. It kind of gets to the parts that other therapies don't always reach.
这意味着它有助于将事物融入人们的生活中，使它们感觉不那么尖锐，并使它们感觉像是多年前发生的，而不是非常近期发生的。通常当我使用EMDR与某人工作时，他们可能会对我说，哇，我刚刚意识到这发生在，你知道，17年前，但我意识到直到现在，它感觉就像还在发生一样。这就是EMDR帮助你做到的。我总是认为它有点像大脑的干洗，或者，你知道，当你使用洗碗机时，你会觉得，哇，它洗得真干净。对我来说，就是那样。它触及了其他疗法并不总是能触及的部分。
You don't have to necessarily access words and it kind of goes where it needs to go and people can find it to be a really powerful intervention. The next is what's called somatic therapy. This helps to release the stored trauma in the body through movement, breathwork and mindfulness. This might also include things like yoga that can be really really helpful because the ideas of Bessel van der Kol in his brilliant book The Body Holds the Score talks about, you know sometimes when our body is in particular positions, it can be really triggering because our body thinks, oh no, it's going to happen again because this is a position I was in when XYZ happened. And so being able to process the
你不必一定要通过语言来访问它，它会去它需要去的地方，人们会发现这是一种非常强大的干预措施。接下来是所谓的“躯体疗法”。这有助于通过运动、呼吸和正念释放储存在体内的创伤。这可能还包括像瑜伽这样的事情，这真的非常有帮助，因为贝塞尔·范德考克在他出色的书《身体记录一切》中谈到的观点，你知道，有时当我们的身体处于特定姿势时，它可能会非常触发，因为我们的身体认为，哦不，它又要发生了，因为这是我发生某事时所处的姿势。所以能够处理
traumas whilst in certain positions can be really powerful. Also being able to take a look at them from a calmer physiological state where your breathing is regulated can help the brain and the body to work out that it's in the past, it isn't happening now. Internal Family Systems, IFS. I know it might sound a little bit weird. It's the idea that we carry around younger parts or younger versions of ourselves or even versions of other people.
创伤的同时处于某些姿势可能非常强大。此外，能够从更平静的生理状态（你的呼吸得到调节）来看待它们，可以帮助大脑和身体弄清楚它是在过去，现在并没有发生。内在家庭系统（IFS）。我知道这听起来可能有点奇怪。这是一种观点，即我们随身携带年轻的部分或年轻版本的自己，甚至是其他人的版本。
It helps us to heal those inner wounded parts that might sometimes be driving our bus. It might be a six-year-old version of ourselves that's determining what our 40-year-old self is doing in any given moment. So being able to kind of tune in to what their fears, what their drives, what their motivators are, can be really powerful in helping to take back control from that terrified younger child part self, allowing the child to be a child again and allowing you, the compassionate, wise grownup, to then be in charge.
它帮助我们治愈那些有时可能在驾驶我们巴士的内在受伤部分。这可能是一个6岁版本的我们，在任何特定时刻决定我们40岁的自己正在做什么。所以能够调频到他们的恐惧、驱动力、动机是什么，在帮助从那个恐惧的年幼儿童部分夺回控制权方面可能非常强大，让孩子再次成为孩子，并让你，那个富有同情心、智慧的成年人，来负责。
This can be so powerful and can really stop the derailing aspect of complex trauma from stopping you being able to function and to go on and do the brilliant things that you want to be able to do in your adult life. And last but not least we have Schema Therapy that is working on the deep seated core beliefs formed in childhood trauma, which helps people to reframe their sense of self. Many of them will be available in your local NHS services. If you meet the access requirements for that service, alternatively if funds allow or you have insurance,
这可能非常强大，并且可以真正阻止复杂性创伤的脱轨方面，阻止你无法发挥功能，无法继续做你在成年生活中想要做的精彩事情。最后但并非最不重要的是，我们有“图式疗法”，它致力于解决童年创伤中形成的深层核心信念，这有助于人们重构他们的自我意识。其中许多疗法在当地的NHS服务中都可以获得。如果你符合该服务的准入要求，或者如果资金允许或你有保险，
you can access private therapy with clinicians who are trained and qualified to be able to work through these approaches with you. If you are watching on YouTube, I would love your comments. Have you received any of these therapies? Have you heard of these therapies before? What are your hopes, your thoughts, your reflections? Please do let us know in the comments and if you resonate with anybody else in the comments, please do feel free to support them too, because it's so important. If you are a clinician, is this helping you feel inspired about wanting to learn these approaches so that you can help people in future too?
你可以与受过培训并有资格与你一起通过这些方法工作的临床医生进行私人治疗。如果你正在YouTube上观看，我很期待你的评论。你接受过这些疗法吗？你以前听说过这些疗法吗？你的希望、想法、反思是什么？请务必在评论中告诉我们，如果你对评论中的任何人产生共鸣，也请随时支持他们，因为这非常重要。如果你是一名临床医生，这是否让你感到受到启发，想要学习这些方法，以便将来也能帮助人们？
This might be a really nice opportunity to give a shout out to the people that trained me in EMDR. So Sandy Reichman, which is S-A-N-D-I, Reichman is R-I-C-H-M-A-N, and she trained me in EMDR through her company, but my EMDR supervisor, Dr Alexandra Button, is now running her own training events too. I don't get paid for telling you that, but I think it's really helpful to push you in the right direction if you do want to access quality robust training in EMDR. Now in order to be trained in EMDR in the UK you do need to have a professional qualification
这可能是一个非常好的机会，向培训我的EMDR的人表示感谢。所以桑迪·赖克曼（Sandy Reichman），拼写是S-A-N-D-I，赖克曼是R-I-C-H-M-A-N，她通过她的公司培训了我EMDR，但我的EMDR主管亚历山德拉·巴顿博士（Dr Alexandra Button）现在也在举办她自己的培训活动。我告诉你们这些并没有得到报酬，但我认为如果你确实想获得高质量、稳健的EMDR培训，这真的很有帮助，可以把你推向正确的方向。现在，要在英国接受EMDR培训，你确实需要已经拥有专业资格
already or be in your final year of something like a trainee psychologist doctorate. More information about that will be available on both Sandy Reichman's website and Dr Alex Button's website too. I will pop a link in the show notes and in the description. So what did you make of Sarah's story? Does she remind you of anyone that you have worked with or yourself or someone that you care about? If this has resonated with you, I want you to know that you are not broken. Your trauma responses most definitely have made sense for you in the past in order to help you to feel safe.
或者处于像实习心理学家博士学位这样的最后一年。关于这一点，更多信息将在桑迪·赖克曼的网站和亚历克斯·巴顿博士的网站上提供。我会在节目说明和描述中放一个链接。那么你觉得莎拉的故事怎么样？她让你想起你共事过的任何人，或者你自己，或者你在乎的人吗？如果这引起了你的共鸣，我想让你知道你并没有破碎。你的创伤反应在过去绝对对你有意义，为了帮助你感到安全。
I also want you to know that healing is possible, even if right now it feels like it's out of reach. If you would like to learn methods to stabilize yourself, to learn about yourself and to learn about the unique impacts of complex trauma on your childhood and your adult self, please do consider the Feel Better Academy. If you would like £10 off the purchase price of the Feel Better Academy, please use the code YouTube10 on my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk. The Feel Better Academy is a really useful program both for aspiring psychologists or mental health professionals to learn techniques to use with
我也想让你知道，治愈是可能的，即使现在感觉它遥不可及。如果你想学习稳定自己的方法，了解自己，并了解复杂性创伤对你的童年和成年自我的独特影响，请考虑“感觉更好学院”（Feel Better Academy）。如果你想获得“感觉更好学院”购买价格10英镑的折扣，请在我的网站www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk上使用代码YouTube10。“感觉更好学院”是一个非常有用的项目，既适合有抱负的心理学家或心理健康专业人士学习与
their clients but it's actually designed for clients themselves to be able to go through and learn ways to self-soothe themselves which really do help people to make massive improvements in terms of their well-being and their functioning. It's all of the ways that I would usually work with a client in a one-to-one capacity but it's in a pre-recorded format that you can access whenever the time is right for you with unlimited access. Okay so that brings us to the end of our main content for today's session. I hope it's felt okay to listen to.
他们的客户一起使用的技术，但它实际上是为客户自己设计的，让他们能够通过并学习自我安抚的方法，这确实能帮助人们在幸福感和功能方面取得巨大的进步。这都是我通常会与客户一对一工作的方式，但它是一种预先录制的格式，你可以在时间合适时随时访问，并拥有无限访问权限。好了，这把我们带到了今天会议主要内容的结尾。我希望听起来感觉还可以。
I hope you've been able to keep yourself safe. Please do consider reaching out to mental health services if you feel like now is the right time for you to do so. Please do also consider Feel Better Academy if you feel like you can keep yourself safe currently but would like to make changes going forwards. Has this episode been helpful? Honestly, the kindest, best thing you can do for any content creator and podcaster that you rate
我希望你能够保护好自己。如果你觉得现在是时候了，请务必考虑寻求心理健康服务。如果你觉得目前能保护好自己，但希望在未来做出改变，也请务必考虑“感觉更好学院”。这一集有帮助吗？老实说，你可以为你评价的任何内容创作者和播客做的最友善、最好的事情
is to like their content, to subscribe to the channel and to drop a comment. And if you like an episode, to share it with your network or a particular person too, it really is the best way to say thank you for free. And if you are listening on Spotify, please do rate the show. Five out of five would be very welcome. And if you're listening on Apple podcasts,
就是点赞他们的内容，订阅频道并留下评论。如果你喜欢某一集，也可以将其分享给你的网络或特定的人，这确实是免费说谢谢的最好方式。如果你在Spotify上收听，请务必给节目评分。五分之五将非常受欢迎。如果你在Apple播客上收听，
please do rate and review the show as it helps to demonstrate to others that this is worth tuning into. Please do also follow the show, The Aspiring Psychologist podcast, wherever you get your podcasts. If you are an aspiring psychologist and you're ready for the next step, please also check out The Aspiring Psychologist membership where we are doing brilliant things looking at research, at formulation, at CBT skills and helping you to develop the confidence skills and expertise to do really well at interview. More information is available on my website www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk. You can also grab your free psychology success guide from that website too.
请务必评分和评论该节目，因为它有助于向他人证明这值得收听。也请务必关注该节目《有抱负的心理学家》播客，无论你在哪里获取播客。如果你是一位有抱负的心理学家，并且准备好迈出下一步，也请查看“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”，我们在那里做着出色的事情，研究研究、制定方案、CBT技能，并帮助你发展信心、技能和专业知识，以便在面试中表现出色。更多信息可在我的网站www.aspiring-psychologist.co.uk上获得。你也可以从该网站获取免费的心理学成功指南。
Come along to my free Facebook community, the aspiring psychologist community with Dr Marianne Trent, which is the exclusive home of Marianne's motivation and mindset videos, which happen on Fridays. My name is Diakolo La Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK,
来参加我的免费Facebook社区，与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起的“有抱负的心理学家社区”，这是玛丽安的动力和心态视频的独家主页，这些视频在周五发布。我叫Diakolo La Amujo。我是爱尔兰的一名心理学应届毕业生。我也是一名有抱负的临床心理学家。玛丽安博士的书《临床心理学家合集》对我成为临床心理学家的旅程非常有帮助。当我计划在英国继续研究生学习时，
I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK decline site application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both information on the UKD Clean Side Application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and trained clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favourite part of the book as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现这本书提供了关于英国DClinPsy申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我喜欢阅读合格和受训临床心理学家的经历。各种叙述是我书中最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不同，它为临床心理学之旅提供了惊人的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。